- Well, now you're in the
final season of "This Is Us."
So, what's going on with
your character Rebecca?
- Oh, way to bring it down.
(Kelly laughing)
So, we're tying up,
you know over a 100 episodes of this show,
and telling the story of this family,
and my character.
Present day, obviously, I
play this woman from 25 to 85.
In present day, she's due with
dementia with Alzheimer's.
So, it's quite heartbreaking,
but I love that we're able
to have this conversation,
and hopefully, destigmatize
the conversation
around Alzheimer's,
and including the family
and all of the the decisions
that like everyone as a unit,
collectively has to make together.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm so excited that we get
to sort of wrap up this story
in a really beautiful way.
And I think people are
gonna be happy with us
the way we stick the landing as it were.
- Yeah. Is it?
I have a question 'cause is it hard
to snap out of that when you leave work?
'Cause y'all do cover so
many serious situations
and scenarios within family dynamics.
Is that hard to like
compartmentalize when you go home?
- I think like for me,
especially in this particular situation,
like I grieve for my character.
My character is very
intentional, she's very stoic.
She has so much grace,
the way she's sort of
handling this diagnosis.
And I as Mandy, have to not
let my feelings for her,
my sadness, my grief,
kind of bleed into the performance.
So, it's like I'll sometimes
leave set and get back,
you know, to my trailer or in
my car and just like, "Ugh!"
It's an emotional release.
But also, there's so much
levity in between takes,
everybody's so funny on the show.
Like we do find ways to sort
of like crack jokes in between,
'cause otherwise it would be
a horrible work environment.
- Everybody's just sad?
- Exactly.
Just crying all the time.
So yeah, ye have to find
a way to like liven it up.
- Yeah, I love your cast.
We've had almost everybody on here.
We love your cast.
- It's the most remarkable group of people
I feel so lucky that I've been,
like spent the last six
years of my life with them.
I love them so deeply.
- And that's awesome.
- Yeah, they're the best.
- Well, what has it meant to you,
that y'all shown so much
diversity on the show?
Especially within a
family, like one family.
- Yeah, the family dynamics,
but what a family can look like.
I mean I'm so grateful again
that we've had the opportunity
that people have been
interested in the show
from the very beginning.
And have kind of come along
on this journey with us
for the last six years.
I think it's the conversations
we've been able to
elicit are so important.
Yeah, it's been the greatest gift
to be a part of something
that's so cathartic,
and emotional, and also reflective of,
even though there's so much specificity
in who these people are in
these different stories,
people are still able
to see themselves in it,
and that's such a gift.
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that is a gift.
Be a part of something that means-
- Yeah, that means something to people.
(audience clapping)
- Well, thank you so much, Mandy.
We love having you on.
- Thank you.
So good to see you.
- [Kelly] You can see the
final season of "This Is Us,"
Tuesdays on NBC.